what's the difference in creating the
the console versus the PC I also have to
admit I've never
um is this shameful actually you should
recommend to me I've never played Skyrim
or any uh any of the games you've
created on Xbox really yeah and on
Console I I played I managed to play
very little actually yeah sure I mean
look there's there's the obvious
interface part between mouse and
keyboard and then a controller but when
you're looking at Hardware PCS it's
tough right because you're looking at
well
you know what are their driver versions
what kind of monitor they have what is
the actual refresh rate of x y and z
um we're used to it yeah but if you know
anyone will tell you give me the
hardware that I know I'm writing it for
you know this
um and the the series X is just a
incredible machine
and now you know what it is you know you
know what it is and and now that we're
part of Xbox getting you know the people
who built it to show you how to make it
really really dance is it's just awesome
is there a case to be made did you get
people that enjoy people that do both PC
and Xbox that enjoy Xbox more like that
if they have a choice yeah they they
enjoy it I think that depends on
and look now that you you can kind of
cross you can take your Save and Go
between and all those things you can
yeah
if you depends on if for which games so
for this Skyrim if you have the Game
Pass PC version of it versus Team not
not via steam right now and so there's
the GamePad so I'm like learning about
this because there's a Microsoft gate so
this is going to be on Game Pass
and then you can if yeah if you can take
it from PC through game pass but I think
it depends on like
like for me like what's my physical mood
do I want to lean back on a sofa exactly
right like the actual physicality of it
is what determines where I want to play
do I want to be two feet from a thing
right now and sometimes I like that I am
more of a console player just because
I sit on my PC at work all day like I
play a lot of video games so when I get
home and I want to play somebody else
like I am a sofa screen controller
person